what's poppin rockstars this is the big
question the show that gives you too
much information about whether or not
the fact that i take a glass of water
with me to bed at night
is my own decision or if it's the
machinations of a vengeful god who wants
me to spill water in the middle of the
night or even worse
make me wet myself my name is mt
and i'm here today with the wonderful
amazing the one and only
jessica clemens what's going on jess hi
i never drink water before bed i heard
it gives you nightmares
hit me with that big question jessica
what is the big question of the day
hmm you guys in the thrilling season
finale of loki we learned that he who
remains orchestrated the events that led
loki
and sylvie write to him he had it all
written out in a script which leads us
to this week's big question
and honestly you guys a
horrible and great big question does
free
will exist in the marvel cinematic
universe
it's a big question it's a reality this
is this is the biggest
question yo kang he was secretly
controlling everything the entire time
that's a huge revelation so
like it's people are wondering do does
anyone even have free will like what the
heck over the past decade we've seen so
many important moments in the mcu but
have all the choices that all of our
heroes made come from a place of free
will
or were they all predetermined by he who
remains aka
kang but not really kang it's not
technical whatever anyway let's start by
defining
free will free will not not free willy
the movie with the with the whale
that's that's different and and and not
tang i accidentally called
kang tang like so let's start by
defining
free will free will is the ability
humans have to decide how to act in
certain situations
independent of natural social or divine
restraints
so when loki until we finally arrive at
the citadel at the end of time and
confront he who remains
he shows them a script and the script
claims to be the path carefully laid out
by he who remains to
bring both loki and sylvie to that very
moment he tells loki that he was just
a flea on the back of the dragon in for
one hell of a ride
even the tea he pours for them is
predetermined
as our loki prefers two sugars and he
who remains
knows it all and sees it all and he is
able to observe
all of time and because of this he is
able to pave the road
for sylvie and loki to walk down but
let's also consider the fact that he who
remains created the tva
in order to maintain a sacred timeline
and prevent another variant of himself
from conquering the timeline the fact
that the tva has to prune variants in
branch timelines in order to keep things
moving
in the direction that he who remains
wants would mean that there must be some
free will out there otherwise he who
remains would just write the exact
script he wants for this timeline and
then sit back and relax
while it just goes but ultimately this
control brings him no solace or peace so
he paves this road for loki and sylvie
to walk down lined with monuments of
influence that will build their
character and persuade their decisions
so that when they ultimately meet
he who remains they will make the choice
that he wants or at least
one of them will okay so that's
completely you know not free will
that is all the exact opposite of what
free will is
i love him to death i think he's very
fun but that is not free will
and i do not enjoy that yeah it doesn't
seem like free will at all
especially if you know he's in charge
essentially oh
and yeah and all you had to say was the
line of like you are a flea on the back
of a drag
also super huge ego you are a flea on
the back of my
dragon like scale spine and i'm just
letting you stay here for the ride
so it's like wow yeah he ultimately
it he has the script he knows your
sugars he literally is like i'm here to
make sure i don't ruin everything he
sees you when you're sleeping he knows
when you're awake
so he definitely okay if we're going
list by list checking off
free will or not free will this is not
free will
yes for sure i would not count this as
free will at all this is definitely
kang just you know like like i said
before he's he paid the path for loki
and sylvia like
that's definitely not free will even
though sylvie this entire time
thought that she was fighting against
free will she was basically just
following kang's plan
which honestly is like
girl when you were a child they made you
sign
like a bunch of pages of what you've
said your entire life
you you were never free you were never
free
seriously i love how they made like a
small child sign all this paperwork like
where like you're not even gonna like
take the mother too which is like all
right you
signed everything like i'd be like i
don't even know how to write
i can't read so of course as we've
discussed
it doesn't seem like there's any free
will for loki and sylvie but
what does this all mean for the rest of
the mcu like is there any free will at
all in this universe
it appears as though anything that has
deviated from he who remains a script
would have been pruned off by the tva so
does that mean
that there is no free will in the mcu
let's look at some key points and see
how they
would have played into he who remains as
planned shall we
i'll take uh no free will for 500 trebek
i'll take a vowel no
i'll
can i finish the sentence there's no
free will in the mcu
but i still stand by the fact that we
have the uh celestials at the very end
of everything
it's like we don't really i don't i
don't know let's get into it let's get
into it okay okay
okay we get into it so let us begin with
one of the biggest moments in the mcu
the creation of
the iron man tony stark himself tony
could have decided to keep making
weapons and he could have forgotten all
about his mark 1 suit and continued his
life as a philandering playboy but
instead he chose
this life of being a hero and ultimately
saving the universe which we are all
grateful for because he is iron man
so was it free will that made the choice
for tony or would he have always made
that choice based on his experiences
and did he who remains said all of this
in motion what do you think jess
he had to he had to and also because i
think there is variance of him in
different
level different whatevers that didn't
that chose to
not listen to the doctor and just was
like no i'm gonna keep
philandering around as a playboy there's
so many different various
variations variations of him that i'm
sure
that all of it has been written by he
who remains
i think and they also said in the tva
with the avengers they were like loki
you can't be a hero
these are the people that are supposed
to be heroes so it's like they already
knew that the avengers are the avengers
and this is what they can do
so i yeah he who remains definitely made
it
but does tony stark have his own kind of
free will i feel like yes
but see if he remains set at all
emotions he's like
it isn't yeah like it seems that he
would it wouldn't have free will it
seems like tony stark would like be sort
of
beholden by this storyteller of he who
remains
um which is kind of crazy because he
will remains will sort of kind of be the
kevin feige
of everything uh black kevin feige
he was
[Laughter]
not david spade but jonathan major
but going back you i think you're right
ultimately
he does not have free will uh tony stark
yeah
it just doesn't seem that way just given
the way that the loki finale went
so let's take a look at the man himself
steve rogers
uh old man uh the first avenger captain
america
uh no longer captain america he was the
first captain america now we got
that uh that good brown version you know
what i'm saying that
sam wilson i'm saying love me some sam
wilson cap
anyway had he not tried to enroll in the
military one more time after several
rejections
he would have never been discovered by
dr ersky so was steve rogers becoming
captain america
an example of free will or did he
remains set this emotion as well just
because you're chosen doesn't mean you
still don't have free will
because you choose whether you want to
take it or not right
um right like so yeah that is a good
that is a good point cause like he did
choose whether or not he wanted to take
it but like
was this he who remains sort of like
manipulating it
okay so we're watching this very this
this this version of captain america
so there is probably another captain
america who could have been the main
character for our mcu
that chose not to take it and so
the one story that we're watching is the
oh my god i need to write this down
write that down write that down
what we're watching is he who remains
story
choosing this captain america to sign
yes on it but there's probably another
one that said no and he was like
that's fine for this one but this i need
one of you guys to say yes
and was just like which one's gonna say
yes yes
yes yes because when it comes down to
like that it's like what timelines
oh this is math and i did not take math
in college so what
timeline has every different story
because they're just little branches you
know it's like
he can say like this is the one i'm
going to go with they said no
okay fine i'm going to pull out this one
that said yes so ultimately
this one that we saw said yes this this
our captain america and this timeline
said yes yes yes basically all these
timelines are basically everyone's
free will but like the he but kang is
basically saying like all right i need
this particular
instance where like these particular
things happen in this moment so like
you know it is like is this really yeah
free will or is this just
kang just choosing a particular cycle to
go with so like
yeah yeah so this is this is why we're
having a discussion because we don't
know whether this is free will or not
ah this is futurama
this is all i we're getting into a
branch angelica
is so good at doing this when we did
rogue theory i was like you're so good
at breaking this stuff down because she
loves sci-fi
i literally she's great i have a sharpie
and a notepad next to me
because i can't keep track it's like
angelica loves that star trek stuff so
like she's a sci-fi
perfect at it but i oh
okay so with that being said i this
captain america was going to say yes
regardless he was like i'm tired of
being tiny
i wanna fight going back to the the part
the part at the beginning i said how
like they were like you are born to be a
villain
they are born to be heroes it seems like
these people were already gonna be
heroes like captain america was already
gonna say yes regardless irregardless
and like he was gonna do all the same
stuff he was gonna do so it probably
didn't take too much
of like he who remains finessing to make
sure it happened
like he was like this guy's name is
captain america it was probably up until
civil war where he was like oh
god great what are we gonna do now he
was like great
he's saving someone that should be a bad
guy but of course let's talk about
the avengers because when a young nick
fury meets captain marvel
his eyes or eye were suddenly opened to
a whole new
host of threats to life on this planet
earth and he then begins a quest to
gather a group of individuals
able to protect us and he didn't begin
his journey with the need to form the
avengers but once presented with the
dangers
facing humanity did he have any other
options was it free will that led him to
form the avengers or
was it the perfect result of all that he
had experienced
okay you answered this first okay
see this is this again goes back to our
talk and we keep coming back to this
sort of about lido free will
in like how the timelines in the mcu
work
and you know this could be the actions
that kang
is allowed the free will actions that
king is allowing to happen
whereas like you said in other timelines
you know nick fury's like ah
i'm not gonna do the avengers it'll be
fine but like you know
bad things happen nick fury is dead and
probably more than
70 of the timelines he is not alive
all these characters within the mcu are
just so dynamic and they're so
they deal with so much conflict and so
much internal struggle
that it'd be weird to think that they
didn't have free will
um but it's just like it's just the free
will that is being allowed to
happen so like if any i would say if
anyone didn't have free will
it's those people who are getting their
timelines pruned because they're
getting there the stage of that free
will is being taken away so that there's
no stage to do it
so you know i think that there could be
free will agreed
agreed with all of that 100 say i would
say
i say now agree all this stuff is really
confusing so like
it's okay if you don't you need that
damn white board
you need the pepe sylvia going on
like honestly yes
it's it's a lot of good we need kang's
chalkboards in the background of the
finale we need to see what was on those
chalkboards i don't know if i could be
here anymore multiverse is getting into
something i can't keep track of it is
it's too much so many levels of me
having i'm gonna tattoo the levels on me
like it's prison break
i'm gonna put it all on my back and i'm
gonna figure out it's so
many levels dude so this leads us
possibly to the biggest threat of life
to the mcu so far
thanos and he succeeded in completing
his life's mission unfortunately
for half of everybody alive and because
of that we get the events of avengers ed
game that create the loki variant that
branches off
from the sacred timeline and this is the
variant that walks down he who remains
paved road was thanos expressing free
will at all when he completed the snap
did he make that decision or was this
just what he who remains wanted
all along i honestly disagree
i don't think it was i think this was a
huge problem that they were not
expecting
the avengers in eddie game the avengers
an endgame but also
i don't think he who remains would have
it would have been okay with being
uh cut out of the whole timeline i don't
think he would have allowed that to
happen
um so i think thanos being who he
is who is still like a god did it and
had free will to do it
okay so you think that thanos had the
free will to do it i think that you're
probably right given like as this
conversation has gone through i think
that
and thanos's will is something that
thanos is so prideful of like it's it's
the very thing that
caesar's like yo like i'm the only one
with the will to get this thing done
because it has to be done
because no one else wants to do it
because they have feelings and they have
they're not a sociopath like me
but again it's the tva that monitors and
regulates
who gets to stay alive to have free will
now let's take a look at doctor strange
and we all saw in avengers end game how
the ancient one
knew that steven strange would
ultimately become the sorcerer supreme
he made the decision to take his eyes
off the road in that split second
that led to his injury an injury that
would begin his quest for treatment
ultimately leading him to commertage or
was it never his decision
like would the accident have happened
regardless of his driving behavior he is
another key player in the events of
avengers end game so
does that mean that he who remains
snipped any variants that didn't get
into that wreck
which is really kind of crazy to think
about because
that accident was probably the biggest
nexus event
like one of the biggest events ever damn
it there he goes talking about his phone
sliding in the rain god damn it
um i think that that one makes more
sense of like
them snipping the parts at the beginning
and then he follows the rest through
you know i think you're right there
because um in doctor strange one of the
biggest
um reasons why doctor strange could even
defeat
uh dormammu dom mama in the first place
dom mama the doma mtv's
no no but seriously um one of the
biggest reasons why
doctor strange was able to defeat
dormammu is because dormammu lives in
his universe
outside of time he did not have time in
at all right so if if k is a being that
is conquering all these universes that
have time in them
i don't think that uh he would be able
to manipulate
the actions of a being outside
absolutely yes but let's move on to
the scarlet witch now who is a very
important character moving forward in
phase four because
she's about to wreck all of reality
because she's depressed again
please go to therapy it's really great i
know i really recommend theory
i'm never gonna go no i'm joking i'm
never gonna do it
i'm gonna go but i might destroy new
jersey
[Music]
who knows but yes she didn't choose to
be placed in the room with the mind
stone and the manifestation of her
powers
since then has often been without her
knowledge of her abilities and
she never intended to create the acts in
west view so does that mean that she
lacks free will
or do her actions in the post-credits
sequence of bonavision
mean that she is transitioning to a
point of free will i agree with the last
part maybe it is transitioning to a
point of free will
because now she's recognizing like her
levels are like her powers are much more
than what she knew and she can
alter create do whatever the hell she
wants but if there was one person that
he who remains messed with the most
other than loki i would say it's scarlet
witch like
this girl did not want to be a part of
anything that she got forced into
so she was like our own sylvie like it
was
because not only did the bomb that hit
her house was stark right it was a stark
bomb
so it's like the uh kang was basically
like hmm
and then maybe like you notice the bomb
hasn't gone off yet
no okay well how about you go and get
worked on by scientists like a lab rat
ski like i feel like he just kept like
ushering her along to be like
say yes or you're gonna keep getting
like messed up with in the timeline
ultron attack b5 thank you
thank you yeah knight to b5
i'll be a knight
the event of one division technically
did happen within
the plan of he who remains so like you
know with if wanda
is becoming the scarlet witch it seems
that this is something that he who
remains
wanted um which is a very interesting
thing like why would he want something
like this because since
considering that um agatha harkness was
like what have you done
this is like this is gonna be the worst
thing ever so it's like hmm
i wonder if he who remains wanted all of
this madness to
to really pop off i was supposed to be
like what if kang is kind of like
not this is a this is a rogue theory
kang needs someone to kind of replace
him or someone to work with and he's
like doctor strange would never
scarlet witch might so he's allowing
this timeline this version of her
to go as far as she can to get the book
to research to do everything
honestly forcing her into like the most
sadness she can deal with just to be
like
now you know how i feel like kane is
now you can be me so like so so she
could be in charge of the tv and all
that stuff yeah
maybe this is such a rogue theory i'm
just guessing that like
he has to have some sort of like want
from her
because she is like she is the most free
will she can be like right now oh my
face what's happening
sorry what's happening no you're totally
right because like
he who remains did set up wanda but he
also knows that all of his variants
would come
so like what if wanda is his weapon that
he's using to fight
all the other kings he's like you know
what i'm gonna give the multiverse a
chance
and i'm gonna release this mentally
non-therapized white woman onto the
cosmos
kill me fight me no i'm just joking
about the whole white woman part it
doesn't matter what race she is
i'm just messing around she's my
favorite white woman yeah she's i love
skeletons
[Laughter]
but in conclusion the most meta thing
about all of this is that these are
characters literally playing out the
events of the script
written out by their creators that's the
weird meta nature of all this discussion
and that these characters in our world
have no free will and that they are
merely creations
of many talented individuals
imaginations and in the marvel comics
there is the character
of the one above all who has been
represented by jack kirby and stan lee
and they control what these heroes did
and now that role is represented by
figures like kevin feige
and the writers and directors that bring
the mcu to life so
perhaps he who remains was right and all
these characters are just walking down
the road that was paid for them and when
ravona rensselaer went through that time
door in the final episode
in search of free will maybe she'll
discover that it never truly existed
in the first place so free will in the
mcu
it's a very it's very interesting weird
gray area but like i feel like as we
learn more about the multiverse
through like shows like what if or you
know quantum mania and
and also obviously multiverse of badness
we'll get a sense of like
how these timelines work and whether or
not you know
every timeline every every person in
every timeline has free will
but the tva was just you know pruning
the free will
into um to make a one timeline where
everything happens
exactly the way they want it's this is a
very philosophical attack
this is a deep big question i never want
to do it again
but one way you can test your own free
will is by checking out our merch
at new rockstarsmerch.com that's right
it's capitalism time
we've got a limited supply of loki merch
left along with some exclusive
black widow inspired merch like this
shirt right here
it's not gonna be over here forever okay
it's you gotta
make sure you pick it up because it's
literally the most important thing that
i own
it's a great way to support the channel
and all the awesome content that we are
predetermined
to make so head on over and check out
our merch options over
at newrockstarsmerge.com some words from
the folks that help bring
big question to you folks like coinbase
cryptocurrency might feel like a secret
or exclusive club but coinbase believes
that everyone everywhere should be able
to get in the door so whether you've
been trading for years
or just getting started coinbase can
help coinbase offers a trusted
and easy-to-use platform to buy sell and
spend cryptocurrency and they support
the most popular digital currencies on
the market
and make them accessible to everyone
they offer portfolio management and
protection
learning resources and a mobile app so
you can trade securely and monitor your
crypto
all in one place and millions of people
in over 100 countries
trust coinbase with their digital assets
and whether you're looking to diversify
just getting started or searching for a
better way to access crypto markets
start today with coinbase for a limited
time new users can get
five dollars in free bitcoin when you
sign up today at
coinbase.com bigquestion sign up at
coinbase.com slash big question
for five dollars in free bitcoin it's
pretty neat
and this offer is a limited time only so
be sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com
big question all right jess are you
ready for
this bite size question yes
[Music]
yes all right
that's good enough for me all right so
today's bite size question comes from
twin on discord just the twin that's
just her name twin that's it
interesting not twins it's not plural so
this is just the one twin we don't know
she got rid of the other twins
[Laughter]
it says is the sacred timeline a loop or
is it linear and how does the sorcerer's
supreme
truly see the outcomes of multiple
possibilities
when doctor strange utilized the time
stone to observe the 14
605 possible outcomes of their battle
with thanos he didn't just view them as
some sort of casual observer
he had to live and die through each
encounter and just before he died in the
moment
reset the timeline and start again this
is similar to the time loop he created
with darmamu where he died over and over
again
so doctor strange is very familiar with
many ways he can die
that's gotta cause some psychological
issues he's a masochist
he's probably going to did that oh my
god first off
yes he's number one anyone that i don't
care what kind of hero you
are you're i don't know i don't know but
you sound like a masochist
and all of the observances that doctor
strange did with the time stone happen
along the sacred timeline so it was
a loop within a loop of time holy crap
this is
true it's true yeah that's pretty that's
a mind f and a half i like that but this
leads us to our
final segment of the show
the box of scraps box of scraps
and this box of craps comes from danny
hell on discord
who asked who would you like to see to
play classic thor because we got
classic loki in loki but we haven't seen
classic four so who would you want to
play a classic thor
what if it was like alec baldwin
like a richard e grant but like it's
alec baldwin
and then you'd see them hanging out in a
room and it'd be very fun to watch them
like
fight each other especially in stature
because richard grant is really tall and
slim and alec baldwin's kind of short
and stubby so it'd be like
like let's fight like weirdos that would
be hilarious
i would and alec baldwin people
feel like oh my god i can't even do it
whisper like this and fight the entire
time
i dig it you know i would i would want
to choose i want to go with
another famous old british actor uh well
elder i don't want to say old like uh
advanced age
um michael caine i think of uh a michael
caine thor would be
michael cantor hello and a master odin
i've got the hammer i'm going to god i
can't even do it i'm going
to mid god i can't even do it
oh now the boston's coming out the
boston the mid god
it's the god guy kid jesus christ
you know uh michael k thor would be
hilarious and weird and wild
but that is it for our episode of big
question thank you of course
to jess for joining me this episode you
can follow her at luluclemons and on
twitch
she is an amazing twitch streamer so
please follow her there if you're into
video games and all that stuff or if you
just like
to hang out with fun people and you
follow me mastertainment on twitter if
you want to see me tweet some weird
stuff but most importantly subscribe to
new rockstars here on youtube and make
sure to hit that notification bell so
you get notifications whenever we upload
a video and make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com find all these cool
shirts
because uh shirts like this are not
gonna last forever alright thank you
guys for watching
and we'll see you guys next time bye-bye
[Music]
you